[Applause]
welcome to [ __ ] ridiculous with DOMA
it's surreal time is what we're renaming
this show I don't know if you've heard
about this I'm gonna talk to you because
you're the only people here but there is
a bug going around everybody has the
sniffles that's got everybody on edge
this country went from zero to crazy in
about three seconds this week and it is
Friday the 13th now there's a pandemic
the markets are in freefall in general
and Trump is president so let's hope we
don't run into a spate of bad luck
you may notice the sound is different
because we're trying to be on the safe
side here and you know people don't want
to come around me I could be the carrier
everybody's [ __ ] nervous you know
especially its donors every time I call
I'm like is that the weed or the virus
the by Aeterna I learned my lesson with
getting stoned during a pandemic because
I got really baked last night and I ate
all the emergency food I have or do we
but you know we've never really seen
anything like this right people I mean
where everything stops we've had
economic problems and slowdowns now are
we being overly cautious
yes but appropriately so we don't really
know what this is yet so every thing is
getting cat cancelling sporting events
are supposed to be in Vegas tonight
sorry can't be there that they canceled
the gay pride parade here in LA and they
said stay at least six feet away when
you talk to the hand
that's the other
advice you see and you know so I'm for
all this masks absolutely I was in 7/11
today two guys were wearing masks they
were robbing it but same it helped
washing hands out for [ __ ] sake I've
washed my hands more times and then when
I murdered that guy I'm telling you
social distancing yes I'm all for that
arm's length no shaking hands don't lean
in when you talk what I call how people
should behave anyway you know what if
you're a head pumping close talker don't
worry about me I've already been
avoiding you is a new trend in Europe
where they're into the head shaking
they're tapping on the elbow why why
touch it all what's the point of
touching someone when you meet them to
verify they're not a ghost
could we try to just get through this
without doing stupid [ __ ] you know to
make it worse that we have to have a run
on toilet paper I'm almost out I was
sitting there going Jesus if only Fox
News had a print edition and also you
know don't stereotype Asian people I
mean it doesn't it's it started in China
it has nothing to do with that I hear
people calling it the Wuhan flu this is
a little insensitive to calling herpes
Coachella surprised you know
all right that's my message just don't
do stupid [ __ ] to make it worse you know
what's up all the businesses are closed
in America except gun sales so American
I'll shoot the virus get off my porch
you [ __ ] virus or I'll blow your what
have you got in there I'll blow it out
we don't do smart stuff in this country
Disneyland announced today that they
were closing down tomorrow tomorrow it's
open today cuz ask any doctor that's
that's how you do it when there's an
outbreak you get everybody together for
one last whiff so you know just be
logical follow the CDC's recommendations
avoid crowds wash your hands don't elect
a [ __ ] president these are simple
things big laughs at home but yeah
there's a new protocol in place because
Trump whenever he talks things get worse
so it's called operations shut the [ __ ]
up he cuz you know Trump he was in the
Rose Garden today and he's lost if he
can't brag about the stock market it's
like a porn star whose dick fell off
he's got nothing and also he's been
exposed exposing himself constantly to
people who have the virus
the Brazilian dude and the guy at the
CPAC and the congressman he needs to be
quarantined lock him up
walk him
and so he made this speech the other
night you know and there's as we know to
Trump's his rally Trump when he's
speaking in public and teleprompter
Trump
that's what you get you got two choices
rally Trump teleprompter Trump you got
Barker at a race riot or safari animal
who's been shot with the tranquilizer
dart because that's who he looks like
when he's talking to the teleprompter I
was watching this I was like I cannot
believe this clown is sitting at the
same desk where Clinton used to get
blown
you